الذكاء الاصطناعي وتواغله في حياتنا
اليوميه وصولا لاصواتنا وهوياتنا هذا ما
وصل اليه جديد التطور بين منافع ذكر
الصناعي وبين المخاوف منه المنافسه بين
شركات التكنولوجيا للاستفاده منه في كل
منتجاتها فشركه سامسونج دخلت على الخط
اعلن تطوير تقنيه جديده تتيح لمستخدمي
هواتف الذكيه انشاء نسخه من صوتهم للرد
على الاتصالات في حال انشغالهم وطبعا مع
كل منتج يتعلق بتقليد الاصوات مباشره تظهر
الخشيه مسائه استخدامه في عمليات احتيال
او تقمص للشخصيات سامسونج رده وقالت انها
تتبع وسيله حمايه تمثل في ان كل مستخدم
يحتاج الى قراءه جمل محدده حتى يمكن انتاج
نسخه خاصه منها بصوتها لكن تظل المواقف
مختلفه حول هذه الخدمات المرتبطه بذكاء
الاصطناعي اسوء استخدامها
استماد المواقع التواصل الاجتماعي على ذاك
الاصطناعي وصل بها الى تقليد صوت المستخدم
واعاده صوت بالرسائل ما مدى خطوره هكذا
تقنيه اليوم نسخ الاصوات في اغلب البنوك
بعد الاحاديث هلا بتعتمد على بصمه الصوت
لتعريف وتاكيد هويه المستخدم وهذا الموضوع
يعني حضرتك ذكرت بالمقدمه انه الشركه قالت
انه انا بدي امن الحمايه عبر انه التسجيل
عده جمل صوتيه تاكد هذا الموضوع للمستخدم
بينما شفنا قبل شركه مايكروسوفت اعلنت عن
برنامج بخلال ثلاث ثواني بس اذا انا سجلت
لك صوتي لمده ثلاث ثواني بقدر اكتب مقاطع
ومقاطع وجمل كتير كبيره وبتكون بصوتك
وبكون عم بقلد صوتك فهذا الموضوع اكيد
عنده خطوره كتير كبيره وراح يقسم بشكل
كثير سلبي على الامن السيبراني
حتى لا نعيش بفكره ظلاميه اكيد دائما في
التكنولوجيا في لها فوائد وبدنا نعرف ليش
طوروها بالاساس فبالتالي هل يمكن الحديث
عن فائده ما من استخدام هذه التقنيه يعني
توظيف صوت طبق الاصل لنا في شيء ما في
تعامل معين
اول شيء خلينا نوضح شغله اللي حكينا عنه
هلا اللي عم نحكي عنه هو منو شي كتير جديد
يعني اول شيء موضوع التحويل النص لصوت من
قبل موضوع تزييف الصوت كمان موجود هن اللي
عم يجربوا الشركات اذا بدك تقدموا خدمات
كاستمايز ويسوقوه لانه هي خدمه مهمه يعني
بكل بساطه هي شو الفكره انت اذا دقيتي له
انا ماني قادر رد في عندي
هلا بدل ما ابعث لك
يبينوا كانه حدا عم بيحكي معك كان عم بحكي
هذا اول نقطه والنقطه الثانيه انه الذكاء
الاصطناعي هذا بخلي انه انا عدت مسج حطن
وحافظهم بقلب هذا السيستم ويصير الذكاء
الاصطناعي يعمل هو جنريت لمسجز مماثله
نفس الشخص بنفس الطريقه يبين انه هذا
السيستم طيب التقنيه تسمح بنسخ الصوت لجمل
محدده رسائل قصيره معينه للرد بها بصوت
المستخدم الى اي مدى هذا يقلل من خطوره
هذه التقنيه ما راح يقلل من خطورتها
بطبيعه الحال لانه بنرجع نقول هلا
هيدي الخدمه اللي عم بيقدموها هلا سامسونج
النقطه اللي فيها انه بس ترد عليك راح
يقول لك انه انا الذكاء الاصطناعي عم رد
عليك بمشي الشخص صهيب محل معين المفروض
تخفف من خطوره انه هي عم تعرف انه مشهور
الشخص اللي عم بيرد عليها بس بنفس الوقت
برجع بقول طبيعه هو عم تحفظ رسايل هو
الشخص عم يكتبها كيف عم تقلد له صوته ممكن
بمحل معين الشخص الثاني يكون عم يسجلهم
يستفيد منهم بقشره ثانيه